[Musique]
oh
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes au centre de moscou dans
l'un des quartiers les plus riches en
histoire le quartier de chitry prodi
chypre ou 10 signifie les étangs propre
pourquoi propre parce qu'ils étaient
sales jusqu'au 19ème siècle en raison
des eaux usées qui s'y déversaient la
ville a même invité des architectes
français pour participer à sa rénovation
et au 20e siècle le fameux architecte
franco suisse le corbusier a par la
suite repris le flambeau pour y
construire un bâtiment célèbre le centro
ça use
c'est dans le quartier de chelsea
produit que se trouve la bibliothèque
tourguéniev
elle est devenue au 10ème siècle la
première salle de lecture gratuite et
accessible pour tout le monde
notre invité d'aujourd'hui vit dans les
livres elle en a et vite c'est elle en a
traduit elle en a même écrit elle
s'appelle anne coldefy faux car elle est
la directrice de la maison d'édition
nouveaux angles allons faire sa
connaissance
à n'en faire votre connaissance moi
aussi très content dire mais on veut
peut-être se tutoyer non sinon ça va
être à ton solennel alors ah non qu'est
ce que tu fais en russie je m'occupe
d'une maison d'édition oui franco russe
depuis c'est la quatrième année
quatrième année oui que tu arrives à
vous ce coup c'est ça oui absolument et
donc ton travail correspond correspond à
quoi qu'est ce que tu fais je suis à
directrice de la maison d'édition
d'accord publie des livres j'essaie de
les faire
j'essaie les diffuser de les faire
vendre et puis petit à petit on et
j'essaie coin équipe de de nous inscrire
dans le paysage éditorial
russe d'accord et les lits sont donc en
français et en russe qui est des livres
en français il ya des livres en russe il
ya des livres en billag il ya des livres
français que je publie aussi en russe en
traduction et inversement d'accord on
essaie vraiment de faire la synthèse des
deux langues ok et des deux cultures
voilà tu me montres des bureaux oui bien
sûr salé à mazet par là allons-y
[Musique]
tu peux m'expliquer qu'est ce que c'est
une maison d'édition une maison
d'édition d'abord on s'imagine que le
travail d'éditeur est purement
intellectuel c'est absolument faux il
est largement autant physique c'est à
dire qu'on passe une bonne partie de son
temps à trimballer des cartons de vivre
et ça c'est très physique
ensuite
c'est compliqué parce que on a à la fois
un travail intellectuel
un travail de contact et direction
d'auteur contact avec les auteurs et les
auteurs sont des gens extrêmement
compliqué c'est à dire que ils sont très
angoissés en général plus leur livre
avance
est proche de la parution plus ils sont
angoissés
plus l'éditeur est angoissé aussi parce
qu'il se dit est-ce que ça va marcher
est ce que ça va me ruiner est-ce que
voilà mais l'éditeur n'est pas censée
montrer ses angoisses
donc ça c'est déjà psychologiquement un
peu lourd l'éditeur est au contraire
censé rassurer son auteur
donc ça c'est un peu et c'est la partie
psychologique un peu fatigante on a la
partie commerciale c'est à dire que un
livre moi ce que je préfère c'est
travailler sur les textes et chercher
des projets c'est travailler sur les
textes sauf que si mes textes
magnifique ne seront pas hébergés tient
pas très longtemps quand quand tu dis tu
tes textes parce que parfois ce sont
aussi ses propres textes ça m'est arrivé
mais pas très lourd que écrite ou même
j'ai écrit mais en général je c'est une
question de déontologie à une exception
près je me plus jeunes eux moto publie
pas
moi je trouve que c'est pas très
très bien d'un point de vue éthique
d'autant plus qu'un éditeur a forcément
un avantage sur
l'écrivain x parce que si lui ne s'auto
publie pas il connaît toujours d'autres
éditeurs
jerry un avantage évident
cage de cnib la nasse et blanc
d'accord pour que je n'aie mode astakhov
michel
bachar c'est quelque chose que
tu as un certain nombre d'années
d'expérience je n'oserais pas dire
beaucoup d'envié ce serait vous jacquou
serait
pas très sympa de ma part
quelle évolution as tu vu pendant toutes
ces années et une énorme évolution est
pas forcément mieux
comme moi j'ai commencé dans l'édition
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance c'était un
milieu où on pouvait commencer comme
j'ai pas à 19 ans comme standardiste
ou bien à l'accueil est terminée comme
éditeur c'était un milieu où vraiment
tout dépendait de votre talent c'est
terminé tout ça c'est à dire maintenant
il ya les diplômes
et à diplôme d'éditeurs c'est un peu
ridicule ce qui fait qu'on n'a plus les
personnalités qu'on pouvait avoir la
tête des maisons d'édition aujourd'hui
et que la qualité même des textes
publiés a énormément baissé parlons du
livre aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on passe de
plus en plus vers des livres
électroniques un joueur comme une grande
mode est ce que c'est ce que tu penses
que c'est la même raison que ça n'est
pas vraiment problème on en fait un
problème mais je pense que sur le fond
il ya beaucoup de gens de toutes
générations qui sont quand même très
attaché au livre papier tu penses que ça
peut ça me fatigue et peut-être aussi je
pense qu est-ce qu on se rappelle de la
même chose
d'après toi on ne lit pas la même façon
moi je le vois très bien sûr quand je
relis un texte ou des épreuves on voit
des choses sur écran qu'on ne voit pas
sur papier et inversement donc il faut
il faut absolument les deux un moment
toi-même l'injuste pas tu as écrit
d'etel quand tu fais tes traduction
stylo un ordinateur là ça dépend
vraiment de l'auteur
un auteur très difficile
je pense à soljenitsyne sur lequel je
travaillais très longtemps soljenitsyne
je peux absolument pas le faire
directement à l'ordinateur
tu participe à des salons de livres en
russie ah oui
par exemple john nixon qui est un salon
que j'aime beaucoup qui a lieu en ce
moment en ce moment d'ailleurs
si tu as envie de venir on a un stand
très bien
le salon du livre non fiction est l'un
des plus importants événements culturels
du monde de l'édition en russie chaque
année il attire environ 40000 visiteurs
professionnels de l'édition critique
littéraire ou simples lecteurs annie
participe comme éditeur pour la
troisième année consécutive
les russes lisent encore beaucoup oui
ils les encore beaucoup et on le voit
dans le métro par exemple où on voit
beaucoup ça me frappe énormément voit
beaucoup de gens jeunes avec des livres
ou avec des tablettes même si beaucoup
de de moins jeunes se plaint que c'est
plus comme avant lui plus au temps
différent mais
franchement je ne prends pas plus grands
pas alors je crois pas et il ya un amour
pour la littérature
française auprès des russes qui a un
intérêt pour la lecture la littérature
française qui ne s'est jamais vraiment
démenti je dirais que peut-être qu'on
connaît mieux les classiques que les
écrivains vraiment contemporain à
l'exception d'un houellebecq qui de
toute façon est connu partout
mais tu as essayé de traduire un
houellebecq aussi maintenant vers la rue
mais je pense que ça vaut pour l'autre
sens c'est à dire que la littérature
russe contemporaine est moins connu en
france de la littérature de ce classique
même s'il ya des gens plutôt connue
qui a pris à
paris ce soir bono
be
nice les missionnaires une élection alex
da kid rock au préfet le sinistre année
en
équipe
et à
nassara de nice à tour président abbas s
immisce n'a commis qu'un bouton b & you
oughta cordiale et du gouvernement en
ces termes de gastronomie qui
connaît beaucoup d'auteurs aussi que tu
as traduit toi même ah oui j'en écoute
il y en a beaucoup qui sont morts
malheureusement mais j'en ai quand même
connu un certain nombre commencer par
sorokine que je connais depuis très
longtemps sans qu'inwi
soljenitsyne août a eu l'occasion de
rencontrer plusieurs fois et la
traduction du cal pas tout seul là on
était toute une équipe mais enfin j'ai
quand-même pour sacrer trente ans de ma
vie est ce qu'il ya des auteurs qui
t'appelle et qui te disent
traduisez mon livre en français s'il
vous plaît peut-être pas à ce point
d'innovations
non mais qui se disent mais je jouerai
peut-être un public en france à ce que
mais oui il y en a il y en a c'est
toujours très difficile de
sont des situations difficiles parce que
leur répondre que
que non ça m'intéresse pas
c'est quand même délicat surtout quand
on les connaît un peu je crois que la
grande
règles pour un traducteur littéraire ces
deux
d'être vraiment passionné parole le
bouquin qui traduit on ignore si si tu
prends un livre
à ce que will est pas mal du lem bien là
ça devient insupportable très vite parce
que là ça devient vraiment difficile tu
été poussé par rien t'es pas
le le texte motive pas assez donc ça
devient réellement difficile et très
ingrat
de livres à tu traduis je dirais j'ai
pas compter ces dernières années mais je
dois pas loin d'une centaine
anne coldefy foccart né en 1951 à
bourges ses grands parents maternels
sont des émigrés russes d'après la
révolution ayant appris le russe avec sa
grand mère anne passe un bac littéraire
et rentre à la sorbonne où elle étudie
la littérature russe elle effectue son
premier voyage en urss en 1970 grâce à
un concours qu'elle remporte anne se
marie à 19 ans tout en faisant ses
études après avoir réussi l'agrégation l
enseigne ruiz en plusieurs lycées
d'abord en région parisienne puis à
paris dès cette époque elle commence à
effectuer des traductions tout en ayant
des contacts avec le monde de l'édition
on lui propose ensuite de rentrer aux
éditions stock pour travailler dans la
collection de littérature étrangère anne
quitte alors l'enseignement scolaire et
travaille pour plusieurs maisons
d'édition en parallèle anpaa sa thèse
qui lui ouvre les portes de
l'enseignement universitaire d'abord à
l'université de caen puis à la sorbonne
où elle anime notamment un séminaire de
traduction littéraire pendant les années
80 anne se rend régulièrement en urss
avec des groupes touristiques pour
maintenir discrètement des contacts avec
des écrivains dissidents tout en menant
en parallèle enseignement et travaille
dans l'édition and publie de nombreuses
traductions d'auteurs russes notamment
gogol dostoïevski ou encore so jénine en
1993 elle décide de créer sa propre
maison d'édition les éditions de
l'inventaire alors qu'elle prend sa
retraite de l'enseignement on lui
propose en 2010 est de venir à moscou
pour prendre la direction d'une maison
d'édition anne a reçu plusieurs prix
pour ses traductions dont en 2020 celle
d'un roman de l'écrivain russe vladimir
sorokine
[Musique]
le lendemain nous avons décidé de nous
promener avec anne dans son marché
préféré à la recherche des spécialités
culinaires russe
alors où est ce qu'on est ici on est en
marche et brave la chan stick d'accord
où je viens assez régulièrement
et je suis un petit peu loin de chez toi
pourtant c'est un peu loin mais c'est un
vrai marché il en reste plus énormément
dans bosco oui y'a des marchés mais qui
sont des marchés un peu chic un peu bobo
je dirais
qu'ils sont bons on trouve des trucs
mais si j'aime bien parce que c'est
vraiment le le marché on trouve de tout
traditionnelle avec les commerçants qui
font goûter les trucs
qui offrent des cadeaux
bon là il fait froid aujourd'hui mais il
fait très froid même mais à l'intérieur
je pense qu'il ya des médias des marchés
intérieurs plusieurs bâtiments oh là où
il fait très chaud et puis en plus l'été
c'est une superbe promenade il ya une
très belle église à côté c'est c'est
vraiment très très agréable et que
j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
c'est bientôt les fêtes de noël est ce
qu'il ya des choses que tu vas acheter
ici pour noël du caviar très bien ouais
forcément c'est le cadeau à ramener ça
oui et puis pour la table de noël c'est
que c'est quand même très bien est ce
que est ce que tu ramènes les rues sont
enfin à noël prépare la salade
olivier la salette vinaigrette alors
peut-être rappeler un peu ce que c'est
la salle a dit oui c'est la macédoine
oui bah ça les vinaigrettes se prépare
très tôt avec tes betteraves ouais mais
ça je ne peux pas les rênes rapporté
gelé les péchés moi tu es chez toi voilà
ça fait partie de ta table de noël quand
tu es en france pas toujours mais mais
oui absolument est ce que ton mari te
demande de rapporter des choses parfois
ah bah oui ça aura par exemple
sahraouis et puis je peux rapporter
aussi des bonbons les bonbons
spécifiques à leur cas est ce qui est ce
qu'il ya des fruits ou des légumes que
tu rapporté que oui
quand j'ai de la place là aussi dans la
valise je rapporte des âmes town of cars
s'est coincé d'ailleurs c'est des pommes
typiquement russe oui un peu acide que
j'aime vraiment beaucoup et surtout
pendant très longtemps je n'ai découvert
jeunes et goûter des hommes tant
d'obstacles récemment oui pour moi
c'était dans la littérature
je savais pas si longtemps j'en avais
rencontré plein dans la littérature et
justement il ya quelques amis j'ai pu
j'ai pu goûter des ordonnances tard tu
as adoré ça j'aime beaucoup j'aimerais
me
[Musique]
donc là c'est les petites sucreries que
tu voulais prendre pour pour des amis
ont des amis qui ont goûté qui trouve ça
très bon tu sais lesquels tu va choisir
mange d'un
match
fou
ces matchs king
goonies à montchanin pas mieux
et ça tu manges sahin souvent non mais
j'aime bien de temps en temps
après avoir fait son marché à ne rentrer
chez elle dans son appartement près des
étangs de chisty prodi
cet endroit pittoresque est devenu un
quartier un peu français c'est ici que
se trouve le lycée français alexandre
dumas l'église saint louis des français
ainsi que le siège de plusieurs sociétés
françaises d'où la présence de nombreux
expatriés francophones qui ont choisi
d'y résider est notre invité n'est pas
une exception beaucoup ce quartier parce
qu'il ya des fans maison intérêts
il ya des lieux un peu historique
des lieux de culture il ya beaucoup de
bibliothèques par exemple et puis c'est
un quartier que je trouve bien qu'il
soit très central et très peuplée
finalement il est encore très vert tu
parles quand même assez bien le russe
les voisins te prennent pour une wii
wheel très content très souvent très
souvent aujourd'hui comment on comment
ça se passe quand tu vis en france en
russie tu lui plus ici quand c'est à
égalité à égalité à égalité je dirais
que six mois de l'année je suis ici mais
pas
des filets qu'à deux filets de corps si
mal année je suis ici mois de l'année je
suis en france parce que j'ai les deux
maisons d'édition mais pas ma famille en
france qui de temps en temps avoir
l'impression j'oublie et le déménagement
en russie ça s'est passé difficilement
au
moscow z une ville que j'adore donc non
ça a été plutôt un plaisir de savoir que
j'allais vivre au moins la moitié de
l'année à moscou
[Musique]
alors le nouvel an tu l'as déjà passées
en russie oui j'ai déjà passé en russie
à des périodes différentes
la première fois que j'allais passer en
russie c'était encore l'union soviétique
la période gorbatchev c'est un peu
compliqué parce que on trouvait rien à
boire
pas d'alcool du tout y compris dans les
magasins pour réserver aux touristes
alors soit ils fabriquaient des choses
plus ou moins buvable je sais qu'on
avait trouvé avec une amie segan on
avait trouvé de l'alcool pour propos
tous les amis et fin mais ça avait été
très compliqué et qu'est ce que c'est
quelle est la différence en fait entre
le nouvel an qu'on pouvait passer en
france et qu'on passait en russie ben
russe et sert il ya la famille et les
amis pour le nouvel an
puisqu'il ya pas de noël
comme 24 24 voilà ton mais d'un autre
côté il ya quand même comme il ya
beaucoup d'élus mination beaucoup de
de lumière la neige oui les gens sortent
quand même sorte de leur appartement à
minuit
pour attendre la fin un peu avant minuit
pour attendre la nouvelle année avec les
voisins on se retrouve en bas
on boit quelque chose on s'embrasse je
trouve c'est assez joyeux c'est assez
joyeux ouais c'est donc tu en a refait
des nouvelles en mai si oui après encore
bien sûr
qu'est ce qui a changé ici pour toi
moscou julliard moscou tu connais du pi
tellement d'années oui quel a été pour
toi l'évolution peut tout a changé j'ai
dit pendant très longtemps et même ça
continue on vient pas pendant quelques
mois et déjà des tas de choses qui ont
changé ce qui ce qui me paraît avoir
changé ici beaucoup c'est c'est le
rythme de vie
c'est surtout une espèce de de liberté
de décontraction wii 2
de spontanéité c'était on était beaucoup
plus sous la réserve oui dans la réserve
que jose qui me frappe c'est que toute
l'année j'entends des feux d'artifice il
ya toujours un prétexte bouclier un feu
d'artifice dans un quartier ou un autre
ça ça me fera beaucoup à vous
est ce que tu aimerais rester en russie
oui peut-être que plus jeune je serai
j'aurais pu rester si les conditions
avaient été différentes tout change
tellement aujourd'hui aussi bien ici
qu'en france que tu
n'arrives plus a toujours mesurer les
différences mais tu es aujourd'hui à 50
50 mais ça de reflets et d'un côté et 2
août finalement c'est parce qu'ils
travaillent qui t'oblige à rester non
non pas du tout qui aime bien moi
j'adore ce riz et j'adore cette ville
leur en plus moscou quand j'arrive à
moscou j'ai mes raisons d'être chez moi
je me sens chez moi parce qu arrive en
france je me sens chez moi aussi une
quelque part finalement 50% d'un côté ça
va être ça le fait très bien avec le
regret de ne pas pouvoir voir le tout le
tout en un seul endroit voilà 6 alors
voilà je pense que ce serait bien
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui te montre le plus en
russie
mes animaux que c'est en france mais
quel gede moutons j'ai des pouilles
qu'est ce qui te plaît le plus en russie
tout est impossible mais tout se fait
c'est maman c'est comme si en russe on
postule est a priori qu'on peut monter
en bas et descendre en eau et c'est ça
qui me plaît anne je te remercie nous
ont passé un moment extraordinaire merci
à bout parce que c'était sympa mais ça
m'a obligé à faire le point sur
certaines questions
sur lesquelles je ne réfléchis pas très
souvent bonne continuation
en tout cas est plein de bonnes plein de
succès dans tous les étudiants à merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous l'avons passé avec anne coldefy
foccart qui nous a fait partager sa
passion pour les livres et la
littérature de nouveaux lieux de
nouvelles personnalités toutes aussi
intéressantes vous attendre l'année
prochaine je vous souhaite une bonne
année et vous dis à très bientôt sur
arte france
[Musique]